ولكن هنا في الشرق الأوسط، حيث أتواجد،
فإننا بالطبع نبث من
مركز برامجنا في الشرق الأوسط هنا في أبو
ظبي، والتأثيرات مثيرة للقلق بشكل خاص
لأن هذه المنطقة هي واحدة من
أكثر مناطق العالم تأثراً وأكثر
تعرضًا لتغير المناخ الذي يمكن
رؤيته في  حالات جفاف أشد
وعواصف رملية شديدة وموجات حارة شديدة، نحن
هنا في الإمارات العربية المتحدة على سبيل المثال، مكان
تمت فيه ملاحظة كل هذه العواقب بشكل
لا يمكن إنكاره. يوضح لك هذا الرسم البياني
متوسط ​​​​درجة الحرارة السنوية لدولة
الإمارات على مدار الخمسين عامًا الماضية وبما يتماشى
مع المعدل العالمي  إن اتجاهات الحرارة
لا تهدأ، ومن المؤكد أنها لا تساعد على الإطلاق.
يواجه الناس في جميع أنحاء المنطقة، بما في ذلك دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة، ندرة لا مثيل لها في
المياه
بشكل جيد وفقًا لمعهد الموارد العالمي.
تتعرض 25 دولة
لضغط مائي مرتفع للغاية كل عام،
وهذا ليس مفاجئًا  أن غالبيتها
تقع في منطقة الشرق الأوسط وشمال
أفريقيا، وتقع أربعة من أكبر خمس
دول تعاني من نقص المياه في هذه المنطقة،
وثلاث منها في الخليج الحار الحار، وهي
البحرين والكويت ولبنان وعمان، ثم
أبعد من ذلك إلى قبرص ولكن عبر
منطقة مانا بأكملها 83 من
يعاني جميع السكان من ندرة
المياه، وهو المورد الذي يدعم
وجودنا على الأرض، هل يمكنك أن تتخيل أنه
إذا استمرت هذه الاتجاهات، فإن
أجزاء كبيرة من الشرق الأوسط ستصبح
غير صالحة للسكن بحلول نهاية القرن،
لذا تستعد هذه الدولة لاستضافة قوات الشرطة  لا شك أن
قمة المناخ السنوية التي تعقدها الأمم المتحدة في نهاية
العام 28، والتي ستخفف من حدة القضايا التي
تواجهها كأمة والمنطقة التي
تنتمي إليها ككل،
ستحتل مركز الاهتمام